this is super interesting
in the moments before it became known
that Fox News and Dominion voting
systems settled the Dominion defamation
suit wherein Fox News will pay Dominion
787.5 million dollars when it looked
like this was going to go to trial and
continue to trial towards the end
the lawyers representing Fox News
through Trump and his allies under the
bus and this is absolutely fantastic
Newsweek reports Fox News throws Trump
under the bus and reads Fox news's legal
defense appears to have taken on a new
strategy in the company's fight against
a defamation lawsuit by Dominion voting
systems for the Network's alleged lies
about the company during the 2020
election blaming Donald Trump
critical element to this uh which is a
quote from the article we will put up on
the screen quote the night before the
trial scheduled start attorneys for Fox
News filed documents imploring the judge
overseeing the case to allow them to
introduce evidence arguing the companies
allegedly defamatory claims against
Dominion voting machines were primarily
inspired by Trump's own rhetoric that
the election with dominions involvement
was specifically rigged against him this
is the similar idea that many of the
January 6th rioters tried to invoke as
their legal defense when their cases
were adjudicated it's Trump's fault
Trump told us to Riot Trump told us to
be here whatever and then Trump says I
said peacefully and you know that's
where the debate comes from it's a very
similar argument that Fox News lawyers
were going to make of course the case
ultimately ended up being settled now I
want to be really clear and honest with
you about what this is versus what it is
not this strategy from Fox News saying
trump it was Trump trump was leading
this whole thing this is not Fox News
finding a moral compass or anything of
the sort not even close this is what Fox
News always does we've seen so many
examples of it and and Alex Jones has
done it who's separate from Fox News and
so have many others of these right
Wingers the lawyers will try to come up
with whatever legal argument is best
when they need to do it in a court of
law it is totally separate from what
happens on the air for example when
lawyers argued in court that Tucker
Carlson is an Entertainer he's not a
news person he's an Entertainer
he uses hyperbole he uses exaggeration
you can't hold them legally accountable
for the letter of everything he says it
might look like a news show but
fundamentally Tucker is an Entertainer
and it's not that he's lying it's that
he's using the stylistic tools of
Hyperbole and exaggeration but the zoom
out big picture takeaway here always is
that we have to remember that they want
to be seen as newsworthy and trustworthy
in terms of their Public Presentation
when it becomes legally too hot they
step back and say well that's an opinion
show and this is entertainment and
whatever else the case may be that's the
same here
when they were doing the rep the quote
reporting I I'm using language that
doesn't even make sense it wasn't
reporting when they were doing the
propaganda and lies around Trump
actually won and Dominion voting systems
was part of the rigging and all these
things they were doing it yes primarily
for Ratings but by presenting it as if
they really believe it whether they did
or didn't it's a mixed bag it seems that
Tucker and Laura Ingram and Hannity
didn't believe it but that Maria
Bartiromo did okay it does it doesn't
matter they were presenting it as news
and then now they want to say well
listen I mean we were just kind of
repeating the stuff Trump said it wasn't
so much that we believed it or that we
were trying to defame anybody end of the
line here is 787.5 million dollars
settlement agreed to by dominion and Fox
News Fox News will pay the smartmatic
defamation lawsuit isn't over and
continues after the break I want to dig
in specifically
to this little detail that Fox News will
not have to apologize on air for
defamatory election lies make sure
you're subscribed on the YouTube channel
youtube.com the davidpackman show quick
break right back